place à l'invité politique je reçois ce
soir Mariel dearnè vice-président du
MoDem eurodéputé bonsoir la fracture à
gauche entre Martine auri et manuel Val
ça vous paraît anecdotique ou c'est
grave non ça me paraît grave parce que
c'est lourd c'est une réalité il y a de
gauche il y a une vraie fracture on voit
bien qu'il y a une gauche qui essaie
d'être on va dire progressiste
socialdémocrate ouverte il y a une
gauche qui est dans une ancienne gauche
on va dire pluriel
hein alors après est-ce que ça va aller
jusqu'au bout don ça c'est en tous les
cas fracture c'est vrai c'est lourd et
en même temps on a le sentiment qu'ils
sont tous déjà dans la
prèshollande ils se disent ça sera plus
François Hollande la prochaine fois donc
qui ça peut être il y en a certains qui
sortent du bois pour pas que ça soit
manuel Vals enfin bon on a aussi un
espè non je dis non parce que la
fracture c'est pas de la stratégie ça
c'est une vraie réalité si ça pouvait
derrière au fond être utile pour
recomposer un monde politique à
l'occasion de la prochaine
présidentielle ce serait très très bien
par je pense mais il faut faire boug les
choses vous voyez bien que droite contre
gauche bloc contre bloc je veux dire on
n'avance pas et vous voyez bien que dans
la réalité au fond ils ont plus de
différence entre ces deux gauches que
peut-être avec certains du centre ou du
centre droit pour les réformiste ou
réformateur dans cette recomposition le
modème vous le verriez comment où et
avec qui moi je le vois moteur d'une
force de force de renouvellement du
monde politique on a besoin que ça bouge
on a besoin de redresser le pays on a
besoin de construire le pays on a besoin
beso j' arrive on a besoin de redresser
l'Europe et ça c'est vraiment aussi
important pour la France mais si on a
pas une France en bonne santé on
n'arrivera pas à redresser l'Europe tout
ça est absolument mêlé vous savez vous
savez que notre idée avec François
Baayou c'est de soutenir Alain Jupé
parce que nous pensons que oui ok il
n'est pas du même parti politique que
nous c'est une droite républicaine il
est estimable il est respectable mais
surtout je crois qu'il a
non seulement la capacité mais aussi la
volonté de rassembler large la prochaine
fois s'il est en position de le faire
s'il gagne l'élection primaire et je
crois vital d'avoir à la tête du pays
quelqu'un qui fera des rassemblements
beaucoup plus larges euh Alain Jupé
dites-vous je reviens à la raison de la
grogne de Martin auri et de ses amis la
la la loiel comery vous la voteriez vous
si vous étiez député en France mais
d'abord j'aimerais bien savoir comment
elle va sortir du Conseil des ministres
si ça vous ennuie pas parce que moi
j'aime bien lire les texes aime bien je
ne sais pas vous n'en savez
rien en l'état je pense qu'il y a des
choses qui sont peut-être pas mal
ensuite je suis pas sûr que toucher aux
heures supplémentaires de cette manière
là soit subtile parce la vote en l'état
c'est pour
ça heureusement qu'on heureusement qu'on
a des quelques différences mais vous
savez bien ce que nous disons depuis
plusieurs années oui il faut simplifier
le code du travail oui il faut plus de
souplesse ce que Matthéo Renzi a fait
par exemple avec le contrat unique à
droit progressif c'est ce que nous
demandons avec Françis B longtemps ça je
l'ai pas vu dans le texte ça je trouve
que ça aiderait beaucoup à l'embauche
par exemple vous dites à la Jupé
évidemment pas Nicolas Sarkozi c'est une
question de personne parce que les
programmes économiques vous les avez vu
ils sont les mêmes ils sont d'accord sur
tout je sais pas s'ils sont d'accord sur
toutah vous les avez lu quand même avant
ranger derrière un candidat mais d'abord
je me range pas derrière un candidat
c'est pas comme ça que je parle c'est
pas comme ça que je pense ça va iroui si
c'est Alain Jupé on est derrière sa pas
se ranger derrière comme une espèce de
je ne sais quoi d'armé TER militaire
vous PL pas on est libre et on a un ADN
d'être utile pour le pays je pense que
la candidat mê programme il y en a ave
avec qui vous êtes prêt aller et pas
l'aut je ne sais pas s'ils ont le même
programme et je crois qu'il y a une
question la question de la personnalité
aussi la question de la manière dont
vous vous comportez de la manière dont
vous pensez le
monde le rapport aux autres c'est
extrêmement important oui bien pour il a
pas changé Nicolas Sarkozi on verra s'il
change peut-être qu'il changera il a été
président pendant 5 ans son mon bilan
pour moi n'a pas été un bon bilan on va
parler de ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
à caléis ou de ce qui va s'y passer
plutôt puisque la décision du tribunal
donc a validé l'expulsion elle devrait
prendre plusieurs semaines apparemment
il faudra que les habitants soient
d'accord et ils ont pas l'air tout à
fait d'accord qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez bah je pense d'abord qu'on peut
pas laisser des personnes des réfugiés
des migrants vivent dans des conditions
déplorables lamentables il y a pas un
camp de réfugiés dans le monde qui soit
dans un état dans le même état que le
bidonville de Calais donc ça c'est une
honte dans un pays comme la France
donc oui il fallait que ça cesse mais
après il faut faire les choses bien
intelligemment ça a été fait bien dans
le camp de grande sainte qui est à côté
hein qui était un bidonville infimme
grâce à médecin sans frontière qui a
refait un camp mais aujourd'hui ils sont
dans des conditions qui sont dignes quoi
qui sont des conditions humaines
minimales donc il faut il faut avoir ça
en tête après on peut parler par exemple
des enfants et des mineurs la plupart
d'entre eux tous ceux qui attendent là
beaucoup d'entre eux quand vous les
écoutez les enfants ils veulent
traverser pourquoi parce qu'ils ont de
la famille en face en Grande-Bretagne et
donc moi je dis qu'il faut que le
gouvernement maintenant dise à Monsieur
Cameron que il ne peut pas qu'on dit ça
ça fait 10 ans qu'on dit la même chose
l'Europe est absolument en pagne sur
cette question ça vous fait mal
eurodéputé ça vous fait mal ça me fait
mal mais là je vaux aller jusqu'au bout
s'il y a des jeunes enfants mineurs qui
ont la famille en Grande-Bretagne oui il
faut que David Cameron ouvre sa
frontière comment vous faites pour les
faire ouvrir ça fait 10 ans qu'on dit ça
bien vous reparlez avec Monsieur Cameron
peut-être vous reparlez pas marqu ce
moment c'est plutôt lui qui est en train
de négocier sur l'OPE pas l'ERS oui mais
ça c'est pas très c'est pas la manière
dont les chefs d'État et de gouvernement
se sont comportés moi ne m'agrit pas
j'aurais pas je serais pas rentré dans
le chantage de Monsieur Cameron je pense
que il a allumé un incendie qui joue à
l'apprenti sorcier et je suis pas du
tout sûr que soi-disant ce qu'il a
obtenu va faire en sorte que ce soit le
oui qui va l'emporter en Grande-Bretagne
l'Europe il faut la repenser hier sur ce
plateau Jean-Pierre minignard un proche
de François Hollande disait écoutez il
disait ceci
justement c'est à lui prendre ses
responsabilités et pas seulement
d'ailleurs à l'intérieur de sa famille
politique il est président des Français
c'est-à-dire la France l'Europe
aujourd'hui je reviens de Londres
aujourd'hui je VO bien effectivement la
situation dans laquelle se trouvent les
Anglais peut-être vont-ils quitter
l'Europe regardez aujourd'hui les Belges
ont remis de nouveau des frontières qui
sont qui sont à front ça se délite
quelles grandes initiatives la France
qui est en premier rang des pays
d'Europe va-t-elle prendre c'est ce que
nous voulons c'est ce que nous attendons
t d'accord avec lui je suis 1000 fois
d'accord il y a un délitement complet de
la volonté européenne de la volonté
européenne sommet après sommet les chefs
d'État de gouvernement se réunissent se
rassemblent ne prennent aucune décision
il y a une crise de la prise de décision
il y a une absence de volonté une des
raisons c'est évidemment que les défis
sont immenses donc les réponses elles
sont pas simples
mais min disait hier allez on prend
rendez-vous avec renzy avec Merkel avec
les le
Belux P oui vous ne pouvez avancer à
quelquesuns que s'il un moteur et ce
moteur ça ne peut ê que la France et
l'Allemagne et c'est pourquoi il a
raison Jean-Pierre migna la
responsabilité de François Hollande elle
est immense mais disons les choses ça
fait longtemps qu'on n pas eu président
de la République en France qui soit on
va dire qui incarne une vision
européenne qui l'incarne voyez qui soit
inspiré qui est envie de construire ou
de reconstruire un idéal européen donc
bien sûr qu'il faut avancer et bien sûr
que on a besoin de la France et de
l'Allemagne alors est-ce que la France
et l'Allemagne vont être à ce
rendez-vous qu'est-ce qui se passe en
France et en Allemagne on prépare les
élections de 2017 j'aimerais bien que
ceci puisse être mis de côté et
qu'effectivement il y ait des
initiatives qui soient prises qu'au
moins on avance qu'au moins on prenne
des décisions et qu'on se réunisse pas
pour défaire l'Europe mais pour la faire
merci Mar d'être venu répondre à nos
questions ce soir juste après la pause
on se retrouve la météo et puis le grand
décryptage on revient sur ce qui se
passe ce soir à calé sur les
conséquences notamment européenne à tout
de
suite